uh how are you guys doing today
good
good thank you very much
quite tired our screening was quite late
last night so
oh are you guys in toronto right now
yeah yes
we're in the same hotel
we're the same with different rooms
um so first of all i want to start by
saying how much i enjoyed this movie and
how great of a job you guys both did um
and congrats on being part of the
toronto film festival before we jump
into actually talking about the film i
like asking some curveball questions
just to mix it up a little bit so um i'm
curious why are the british so good at
making period pieces
no i know you're not but i'm just
curious in general you know why are the
british always so good at it
well yeah i don't know i feel like we're
um
we've been good at it for a long time we
need we need it mixing up with hence
ever coming in to save the day
sort of start to mix it up a bit we yeah
we've got a rich tradition of it i guess
um
and i suppose you know we we're steeped
in like
kind of literary classics about certain
periods and and i suppose we we we're
always intrigued to revisit those so
maybe that's it i don't know i mean
my experience now is that i think we are
we're coming into a new age of period
dramas and that's an exciting thing well
and if i may intervene although i'm not
british um
i i think it has to do with a certain
kind of nostalgia of the empire also
josh
you know it's yeah
you know it's it's always in countries
like that that have had
a great
moment in history um god some people are
gonna hate me when i'm asleep
but i mean you know it's like the roman
empire and the italians and you know and
the portuguese and you know oh conquista
it just brings up
um
a desire to
go back to these times and explore them
uh so and and you know in certain
cultures it's sort of a need
and uh and they've become very good at
it
i'm i'm curious ava if uh if you can get
the financing for any project
what would you make and why
um
[Music]
if i could get the financing for any
project
well you can't talk about everything but
i mean there's this
book
that i used to read when i was a kid a
young girl and the main character is
this kick-ass sound engineer and she
visits
different worlds and she's a very very
independent and fierce woman and i grew
up with that role model and actually
really inspired me and i think she's
still very very relevant
and uh
but i know the author who is in his 80s
now doesn't want to sell the rights
so
but one day and that's a massive problem
but it's
it's it's you know it's just one of
things you've grown up with
completely i i hope one day that you do
get the rights and can take that on
josh if you could guest star on a tv
series what would you guest star on and
why
the crown sorry
the crown yeah
um i
reckon
maybe shit's creep
because it's really funny
and um
yeah i think i'm like whenever whenever
i watch i'm now i've actually [ __ ] i've
got a kind of interesting relationship
to because my entire family
my partner my little brother my mum
my dad they've all been raving about
shitscreen and i watched and this is
about an embarrassing admission but i
watched the first three series and i was
just
like it's funny but i just couldn't get
into it
and now
uh then i continued and now i've watched
the whole of the series like three times
and i'm obsessed i think it's hilarious
no i [ __ ] scream i'd love to do that
um jumping into why i actually get to
talk to you guys today uh everyone
watching well almost everyone watching
will not have seen the movie yet and i
hate asking the generic question
but ava could you sort of talk about
what the film is about
i'm very bad at that um
i think the movie is about how hard it
is to be a human being and how amazing
it is to be a human being and how one
doesn't go without the other
and you just you just can't get it both
ways and that's the incredible tragic
beauty of it
and you can look at it
um
it's the half
half full half empty class you know and
i think the movie is about the half full
class
you know even when it's tragic there's
something incredible
that he can gain from it no matter how
hard it is
i that's pretty good i think i think
you're better at it than you think
um one of the things that this film does
so well is capture this period in time
in british history that um was after the
war and you can see the repercussions of
what the war did to all these families
and these people that even though they
have this money they they're miserable
because they've lost so much of their
soul um can you sort of talk about that
josh if you want to talk a little bit
about that aspect of the film
yeah i guess that's one of the reasons i
was excited to
tell this story with eva and odessa and
the team was that i think
it's kind of it's a it's a period that's
actually not that visited you know we
visited the first world war in the
second world war often and we'll
continue to do so because it's such
because of the kind of ramifications and
the ripples that they've uh they've had
on society
um going forward but
actually assessing that gap the the
period in between the first and second
world war we haven't done an awful lot
of and
as you say the sort of trauma
um that was left behind
is huge in every you know in every part
of society and and
um
and obviously mothering sunday focuses
on
party modern sunday focused on this
community
i suppose wealthy you know the kind of
upper middle class
um
but i think
you know the effects you see the effects
with jane you see the effect um later on
in the film i think and we still have
the effects now so um
yeah i think it's a it's an incredibly
important time and
uh
obviously from my perspective it was
about understanding the kind of uh how
impactful it was not to
have you know to have to have lost an
entire generation of young men and
servicemen so
so yeah
it's a fascinating period in our history
uh evo something that i think you do so
well in this film is that you i feel
like it's an authentic depiction of what
two people being intimate would actually
be doing in a room it is and i know that
sounds um i'm trying to say this
so it sounds right but you know all too
often with movies uh people are intimate
and all of a sudden they're fully
dressed and they are you know it's just
it feels fake it feels like you're
watching a movie and what you did with
um odessa and josh uh because you know
the way their performances and the way
you shot it and captured the scenes it
felt very real can you sort of talk
about why uh filming it that way and um
and just that honest depiction
um i don't know i guess you know it's
just it's something that
i think is very interesting you know to
just go back not to the uh
cinematic representation of things but
to draw experience from your own life
and like from you know what you hear
when your friends talk which is
people spend a lot of time
you know being around each other and not
you know intimacy is not just about sex
and that's pretty obvious statement but
it's rarely shown on screen
because when they want to talk about
real intimacy then it's just just about
hot sex and i think sex is like a very
small part of it all really
uh it's important but it's it's also
about
how
it happens afterwards and the level of
comfort and
i thought it was so beautiful to see
that in the script you know when you had
these two characters naked
just hanging out
and being so comfortable with one
another and
when you know the rapport that they have
you know the rapport of social class
differences and
destiny differences
it's remarkable and that's the beauty of
humankind and human beings you know they
tend to be able to
bridge those gaps at in those moments in
life you know when
you know it's i i find it uncanny like
some people have the ability to
just drop everything
everything that has been carefully
constructed
and
instilled in them as social human beings
where you know you should feel this you
should behave like this because they
connect on a human level and they have
an immediate
intimacy that goes beyond everything
i've i've certainly had this experience
i know paul and jane have this
experience and i'm sure a lot of people
in the audience have that and
you know
i
it's
that's the beauty of filmmaking you know
it just allows you to revisit revisit
something that maybe you had access to
once in your lifetime
and to make it yours again and revisit
the movie is about that it's about how
do you make it yours
you know how do you revisit things and
and and enjoy them again they're not
enjoyable just
when you leave them they're enjoyable
also as a cherished
garden within yourself
completely it's just it's interesting to
me and i've had this conversation with
other filmmakers that
uh i don't know what's happened but you
can now be the most do the most brutal
things to the human body in a movie
um in terms of killing and it's accepted
with the you know like the mpaa and
ratings boards but if you show nudity or
sex it's like the walls sometimes come
down um i don't know how it is in europe
but in america it's like that um did you
have any sort of
um opposition from anyone saying this
might be this like putting uh people's i
don't how can i say this uh this honest
depiction
might be an issue or was everyone with
the producers and everyone on board oh
quite the country actually i think
everyone was quite exceptionally um
honest with themselves and what was
needed for the story
and um but it's a matter of sort of of
putting together the right
team of people you know and i'm i'm
talking about producer director actors
josh and odessa were exceptionally
generous
uh i mean afterwards their actual bodies
used to show that intimacy and you know
i i started out as an actress when i was
a teen so i'm i'm acutely aware of
how vulnerable it makes you feel so i'm
i'm very grateful
uh when i have actors who
you know just are not afraid to go there
it's it's not that easy especially
nowadays you know where the image is
you know this seems out of your control
much more easily
um
and uh
and i think that if it's scary
it's because it's honest
you know i think description of violence
you can easily remove yourself from it
it's like you know the doctors in the er
they have to remove themselves from it
because it's too much
but when you get to descriptions of sex
or intimacy
people get caught off guard and and it's
a much more heated subject matter and
you know i think we're entering times
where
um
you know
being free-spirited is not as obvious as
you know it was in other eras but you
know history is like is cyclical
um you know in ancient rome fluidity was
the standard in the 1920s things were
much more fluid than now
you know like people didn't really
verbalize homosexuality or queerness for
example they just were the bloomsbury
group that we got a lot of inspiration
from
everyone was incredibly fluid you know
they were going with
men women like
whatever it was about the sentiment it
was about the feeling the emotion
uh
yeah it's so interesting how how life
has changed uh because i i
uh i have a lot to say on that but i'm
gonna not uh open that door um josh i
definitely want to ask you obviously
this is a very you really have to put
yourself out there in this role and you
really have to i don't want to say go
for it but you're really putting
yourself out there
when you got the script and you realized
what you were going to be asked to do
were you apprehensive at all or were you
sort of like the you know
um i guess were you nervous at all
um no not really i i suppose to me it's
kind of
um
i mean
i'm always nervous going into any world
but the thing that i
suppose
i had nerves about on this one was more
to do with the
the deep sense of sadness that i
you know had to try and lock into for
paul which is this idea of you know paul
has two brothers and i've got two
brothers and
the idea of
losing them and and then having the
extra weight of societal pressure and
and and marrying someone who perhaps
not only do you not
love in that way but actually you love
as someone else you know you love she
was supposed to marry his friend you
know these are like
um
these are people
that he does laughing someone to be with
and so that all that pressure that was
more kind of nerve-wracking as for the
nudity and all that stuff
uh and
i mean i always
but i wouldn't you know i wouldn't do it
lightly it has to be appropriate but
when you read the script and and when
you read the novel there's no way you
could tell this film
um there's not essentially there's not a
better way to describe paul's lack of
um
of emotional articulacy than to show his
then for him to be able to find it in
his physicality and that means
everything everything about the way he
dresses the way he is around
um around jane
and so yeah there was i was never really
nervous or anxious about that
ava i really enjoyed your use of
close-ups in the movie and i'm curious
obviously you know it's big decisions on
how you're going to frame something when
you're shooting uh can you sort of talk
about uh the decision of doing a lot of
close-ups and the way you wanted to
shoot the film
what do you mean the way i wanted to
shoot film sorry well just like the the
framing of how you wanted to tell the
story uh with the use of close-ups in
certain points
um
i tend to try and
not overthink
how i want to film something because it
can
get stifled very easily
and it can get gimmicky
um so i tried to
have a plan but remain very
flexible about it and and i'm talking
about that kind of film because it's a
movie about human emotion emotions you
know it's funny like i've i've
i tried to do very different things you
know my previous movie had a lot of
action in it
and
i find it much harder to shoot emotion
uh action is kind i find it simple you
know you have like a choreography of
things and you decide where you put the
camera and if you visualize things it's
just you know just sort of like falls
into place by itself with emotion you
have to
create
grace
and create magic and create
this moment like in real life when sunny
you're moved by something
so
when i
when i wonder what's the right distance
i always start with the emotion
you know how do they feel
inside you know how do they it's it's
it's about point of view for me and it's
about the the right emotional distance
if they feel very connected to
themselves and the person that's in
front of them i tend to go for a very
um close close-up like a 75 millimeter
and if if they feel stifled or if they
feel trapped in a very conventional role
i tend to like stay away from them
and you know on set that kind of rule
guides you very easily because it makes
choices easier because it's easy to get
lost in the sea of options you're like
ah a lot of things are going to look
beautiful
but if you need to be guided by emotions
that guides also the size
of the frame uh i apologize josh i'm
going to ask you another question but
i'm always curious about the editing
process because that's the final rewrite
and i'm curious because this film jumps
back and forth in time and it mimics the
novel in the way that the story can sort
of go in different directions can you
sort of talk about um
uh getting in the editing room and what
maybe surprised you about the footage or
some of the challenges you maybe uh that
hit you in the editing room
well
you know for me i mean for a lot of
directors there are three stages of
three writing stages there's the script
stage the shooting stage and the editing
stage and each of them brings something
different and requires something that
needs to work
at that moment differently
a scene
might work incredibly well on set and
then
you know if you find yourself needed
you'll realize that in context of the
rhythm of the film and where you need to
be at that point it's too slow too fast
so you have to reshape it
and
you know i just realized for example on
this film
i had
you know so many incredible options
acting wise
you know between takes
so it was definitely not i didn't have
any issue with that what i had an issue
with was so what do i do with that now
like how do i shape it and how do i say
how do i stay
faithful to the actors and to the
generosity of the performance
while extracting
what i need to extract exactly for the
rhythm of the film and the narration and
you know i i tend to think that i don't
direct actors that much on set
you know i just sort of sort of
fine-tuned things but you know then
especially with actors like josh and
odessa and conan olivia they have
this so connected to the right rhythm of
things that is beautiful to witness them
and it's a privilege you know i'm like
oh my god
i'm directing this
you know it's fun and then in the
editing that's when the real fun starts
for me um in terms of directing the
performances because
i can just really be their partners in
the dance at that moment and like push
them just so much further
if needed or on the contrary just like
stay back because
we both nailed exactly what needed to be
done on set
so the editing took a long time took
seven months
um because
it was a very very complex narrative and
it needed to be that
constant dialogue between the acting the
writing the directing the music and it's
it's everything has to like advance
together and so it's a constant ping
pong it just takes time you know
time is is of the essence you know i'd
say
yeah it's it's funny because i i think a
lot of the
a lot of people do not realize what it
really takes to make a movie and all the
behind the scenes especially the editing
process and how much can change um
uh josh wanted to ask you
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of you know the making of movies
and you know what you can't what you
normally don't hear about what is there
anything that you might is there
anything that you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of this
film
um
let me think uh there's lot i mean
there's loads of fun things but i don't
know
[Music]
there's one thing which is to do with
the click
which is that eva was very keen
to find the rhythm of some of the sex
scenes and so sometimes ever would
sometimes who am i kidding all the time
i would click like this
and it would be
it would be to help find a rhythm it was
more to do with the breathing actually
it was to do with like
ever was very keen to find a particular
kind of breathiness because the sound
design and the intimacy of the shots and
so you'd be doing these intimate sex
scenes me and odessa and then in the
background the french one game french
and and i have to say i you know i i i
kept a straight face but i was i was i
felt so much empathy for them because
it's it was so hard and
you know people were were wearing masks
and
i was like i'm just very happy they
don't
like you know
hate me you know officially in public
they were very elegant about it
i'm always curious i know i'm just about
out of time but i'm always curious if
you ended up with with films if they end
up with a lot of deleted scenes uh did
you end up with a lot of deleted scenes
on this no we did it i think
one dialogue scene two dialogue scenes
and and like a couple of other very
small scenes like most of the script is
on screen and and you know we reordered
a lot of things because
what works on the page doesn't
necessarily work on screen in terms of
like real
time real moving time
but that's not to say that alice's
script is not exceptional it's just you
know you just have to do that
transformation
completely um josh i think it's my last
thing for you um i i'm curious when you
are getting ready to do like a big scene
the next day let's arbitrarily say it's
monday and you know this is a big day
of filming where i have to be either
emotionally vulnerable or really just do
a lot how much are you in your head the
night before thinking about everything
you have to do and how much is it sort
of like i can't think about it yet i'm
going to wake up early monday i'm going
to get to set early and i'm going to
remo you know get myself ready i'm i'm
always curious how actors like to
process when they're getting ready to do
something big
um i mean it's i don't know that i have
i've found a kind of
uh sort of proven method for it but i
think
and so it does change i mean there's
definitely been nights where you know
the day after as you say i've got like a
big scene i just haven't slept and then
you're crying on set because you're just
exhausted rather than doing any emotion
but i think
more often than not i mean the big thing
the kind of the struggle i come into is
that i'm my instinct is to always make
people
i guess everyone's instinct is to make
people smile and be friendly and be nice
and courteous
um
but sometimes you have to be a little
bit rude because i think in those in
those moments of
um
of those significant moments you do have
to take yourself away and the the
difficulty of filmmaking is that it is a
team sport and you're surrounded always
by the most
like some of the coolest people you'll
ever meet the nicest and kindest and the
funniest and so
you know to take yourself away and be
like today i won't be making any jokes i
won't be talking to you i'm just off on
my own is quite a hard thing in itself
because you feel terrible and you feel
like you're being rude but i think
the other thing is that peop you know
generally i'm learning that generally
people get it and people understand when
when's the time to kind of
be you know joke around and when it's
time to like
you know leave me or anyone else to it
so
generally i just kind of go off walking
you know in straight lines and
and uh stand in the corner and try and
make myself sad or whatever it is
yeah it's interesting i've spoken to a
lot of actors and they talk about
certain days uh they you know um it's
just interesting how the process is is
so different for everyone and how some
actors can just flip it on in a moment
and others really
i can't do that i can't do that like
i've seen you know olivia coleman and i
can say this because she says it she
said herself olivia coleman could be
having a laugh and the next minute you
know she's you know doing the most
unbelievable performance you've ever
seen and she's growing she's just genius
i just can't do that i have to kind of
take myself into a space and
um i wish i could do that but i just
can't
yeah
i i'm uh i'm sure as time goes on maybe
well who the [ __ ] knows you know you
never know um it was i'm gonna stop
there um but while we're still talking i
just want to say again
how much i enjoyed this movie and both
of your work in it
and i really want to thank you for
giving me your time
thank you